the creature let out an unmistakable
squeal of Rage as stimulus y835 took
effect Dr Christensen pressed his face
up against the glass eager to see the
results it had to work this time it
simply had to he was certain that this
attempt would make all the other
failures worth it and he'd once again
prove the foundation's faith in him to
be well placed
scp-5683 shrieked a loud insect-like
sound that would have normally made the
blood run cold of anyone that heard it
but to Dr Christensen it was like music
a monster's dying Fanfare to mark his
success soon he'd be the researcher who
neutralized not one but two tenacious
highly adaptable anomalies the senior
researcher could feel his heart racing
as the deadly giant spider started to
Twitch then burst into two identical
entities the pair of arachnid anomalies
had reacted much like the results of the
tissue sampled tests conducted earlier
dividing into two separate organisms
Christensen held his breath the tissue
samples had destroyed each other
attacking and injecting the other with
lethal doses of Venom surely he reasoned
duplicating
scp-5683 into two would have the same
result his heart sank as he watched one
of the spider creatures the duplicate
perish almost immediately as it often
did when presented with human prey
scp-5683 attacked using its mandibles
and impaled its copy with its front legs
to pin it in place the Clone had bitten
back with Dr Christensen already knowing
that would have granted
scp-5683 an immunity to its own Venom
its powers of adaptation were fiercely
frustratingly efficient and nothing
demonstrated this more than the intense
reaction from the man tasked with
destroying it Dr Christensen hurled the
nearest object a coffee mug had a glass
window of the observation room
overlooking the test chamber he pounded
his fist against the glass hardly with
the required Force to cause damage but
enough to send pain shooting down
christensen's wrist which then nestled
in his forearm a reminder that the
experiment like the others had failed
why can't I destroy you he muttered
through clenched teeth looking with
hatred at the enormous spider in the
chamber below the directive had reached
him the day immediately after New Year's
Day 2020 and straight from a member of
the o5 council no less their message
expressed how impressed the council was
with Dr christensen's success with the
Doomsday Clock project and how favorably
his name had been mentioned in Council
meetings this voted well for the
ambitious Foundation doctor he'd been
hoping to snag the director position at
site-04 now that director Bray had
retired but there was one more test from
the o5 council the they wanted Dr
Christensen to use the knowledge
garnered during his previous success to
solve the
scp-5683 problem if he could
successfully complete that assignment it
would be his ticket to being promoted
with the comfy role of site director and
all its perks in mind Dr Christensen
accepted the assignment from the council
to deal with
scp-5683
scp-5683 was quite the Beast not an
anomaly for those with intense
Arachnophobia the huge spider-like
organism was extremely hostile towards
humans and had to be kept in a constant
state of medical sedation otherwise it
would relentlessly attempt to breach
containment and Slaughter any and all
Personnel in its path what had made
scp-5683 such a problem for the
foundation was the creature's ability to
rapidly regenerate damage as well as
modify its own body in reaction to
threats much like a certain particularly
hard to destroy reptile The spider-like
Entity could adapt itself to become more
resistant to any danger posed to it and
of course this meant that the foundation
needed this dangerous creature
eradicated the frequent containment
breaches and sheer number of casualties
caused by the arachnid anomaly were
significant enough to cause an
increasing drain on the SCP foundation's
resources so with the termination order
coming from the very top the o5 council
themselves Dr Christensen was tasked
with overseeing the neutralization of
scp-5683 during an initial deliberation
Dr Christensen met with researcher miles
and Hall Junior researcher Silva and
security Chief Ade to discuss earlier
attempts to terminate
scp-5683 the new head of the termination
project was perturbed to learn that the
research team had little in the way of
useful information to offer beyond what
the foundation already knew about the
creature but Christensen decided some
basic stress testing would at least be a
start after a successful tissue sample
test wherein some of
scp-5683's genetic material was
incinerated Dr Christensen tried to
Simply destroy the spider with fire an
understandable response to say the least
however exposing scp-5683 to
temperatures of 850 degrees Celsius for
just 30 seconds didn't quite yield the
easy Victory he had hoped for the
arachnid thrashed about and screeched in
reaction to the heat only to rapidly
develop a form of armor plating covering
its entire body the armor was comprised
of an unknown unidentifiable substance
but it was enough to prevent
scp-5683 from combusting reconvening
with the rest of the team Dr Christensen
hid his pride assuring everyone he was
just trying to establish a baseline
during the previous test of course he
hadn't believed that terminating
scp-5683 with fire would be a success or
so he claimed hiding how much he'd
longed for an easy solution so he could
snatch up the vacant site-04 director
position but to ensure the others
Christensen explained that he'd
requisition some anomalous materials
from the o5 council that they'd be using
in their next termination attempts
nothing that was anomalous enough to
require containment but toxic enough
that they presented a few options for
destroying
scp-5683 uh just for logging purposes
sir may I inquire about the specific
substances we're shipping in junior
researcher Sylvia had asked of course
why 220 y835 and y43 Dr Christensen
quickly recounted them all from memory
I'm told they should be arriving within
the week I expect each would be enough
to do the job but it's best to hedge our
bets this spider doesn't compare to the
lizard I'll tell you that Junior
researcher Silva seemed to take an
interest in what Dr Christensen had just
alluded to his previous work with the
lizard he probed for further about it
and Christensen gave a solemn response
the aspiring Foundation doctor recalled
an incident from a few years earlier
during his experimentation with scp-682
some of the methods Dr Christensen had
opted to employ in an attempt to destroy
the hard to destroy reptile had led to a
severe Containment Breach when
describing it he used the word
unpleasant perhaps out of guilt at how
many personnel had lost their lives due
to his actions brushing the topic aside
he assured the team to get on with
testing the new anomalous stimuli on
scp-5683 stimulus y220 initially showed
some promise during a tissue sample test
it successfully converted part of
scp-5683 into glass which then violently
exploded leaving nothing behind but
attempts to use it to neutralize the
creature itself quickly quash those
promising results within nine seconds of
being exposed to stimulus y220
scp-5683's body rapidly turned to Glass
a around 80 percent of its arachnid Mass
proceeded to explode shattering in all
directions sending clear shards
showering over the testing chamber as he
watched Dr Christensen allowed himself
to believe that this was mission
accomplished that he'd successfully
terminated
scp-5683 but his celebration was
premature the spider quickly began
reconstituting itself its body
regenerating within the space of 30
seconds after testing with both stimuli
y220 and y835 Dr christensen's
frustration seemed to be increasing with
each failed attempt the newest promotion
was Within Reach and as far as he could
remember he'd done good work with
damaging scp-682 why should eradicating
this anomalous spider be any different
however it was a test with stimulus y436
that enraged the ambitious doctor
expecting the anomalous stimulant to
turn
scp-5683 into a fine Mist Christensen
watched as the creature's body vanished
finished literally vaporizing changing
states of matter to little more than
water in the air suddenly every light in
the facility powered off plunging the
testing chamber into darkness when the
lights came back on
scp-5683 was standing on all eight legs
right where it had been missed only
three seconds earlier the research team
had gathered for another mediation and
Dr christensen's anger still hadn't
subsided he kicked a chair to emphasize
his frustration alarming Junior
researcher Silva who urged him to calm
down after eventually cooling his temper
Christensen made an announcement that
caused even greater concern to spread
amongst the team I'm requisitioning y910
researcher halls and researcher miles
objected trying to get Dr Christensen to
realize that the course of this action
was excessive Overkill even but
Christensen disregarded them standing by
his latest method for terminating
scp-5683 the global occult Coalition had
previously used y910 to poison Gods he
felt sure that it would work on one
anomalous giant spider his time was
running short Dr Christensen was aware
that any day now the o5 council would be
appointing a replacement director of
site-04 and he wanted that promotion and
he didn't seem to care what Corners he
cut and what risks he took to get there
even if it meant endangering his
research Personnel Dr Christensen
declared that in order to save time it
would be bypassing tissue samples to
test for termination attempts the longer
it took to terminate the anomalous
arachnid the more his window of
opportunity closed and the further the
director position slipped from his
fingertips accepting full responsibility
for The Reckless decision and anything
that might go wrong Dr Christensen
wanted to use stimulus y910 directly on
scp-5683 he urged the research team to
make the necessary preparations unaware
of what his decision would lead to and
the chaos it had already caused the test
was catastrophic so much so that it
caused a Containment Breach with
scp-5683 loose and scuttling about the
facility on its multiple legs Dr
Christensen and Junior researcher Silva
were forced to rush to the secure bunker
on site for safety Christensen was in
the state of panic until he noticed
something and not for the first time
either he'd been detecting a foul smell
whenever he'd conducted the meetings to
discuss termination options but the
other members of the research team had
quickly explained it was nothing more
than repeated accidents in the cafeteria
but here was the stench again worse than
ever yet Junior researcher Silva brushed
it off again stating that
scp-5683 must have gotten into the
facility's reactor the junior researcher
quickly became inconsolable stating that
the whole situation was his fault Dr
Christensen interjected demanding to
know how it was and what Silva had done
to cause this situation Nation he
replied that it was his duty to oppose
ill-advised actions and when Christensen
had declared his intention to use y910
the Junior researcher hadn't opposed him
Shifting the blame from himself onto his
subordinate Dr Christensen chastised
Silva over how many personnel had died
because of the junior researchers
refusal to do his job ignoring that it
was christensen's own Ambitions that had
led to the current chaos refusing to be
made a scapegoat Dr Christensen vowed to
pin the full culpability for
scp-5683's Containment Breach onto
Junior researcher Silva saying he'd tell
the o5 council the so-called truth about
what had happened but Silva pointed out
that there wasn't much of a likelihood
that the bunker would survive the
reactor overloading he urged the
ambitious Foundation doctor to admit
some responsibility of his own for what
had happened but Christensen refused
suddenly there came a thunderous banging
at the bunker door a debilitating Pang
of fear struck Dr
causing him to scream and Retreat from
the entrance yelling no and please as if
he was pleading with the universe itself
to spare him from the spider Junior
researcher Silva walked over to the
bunker door just as strong arachnid legs
tore the heavy steel bulkhead off its
hinges like it was made of little more
than wet paper there was
scp-5683 the enormous spidering Into the
Bunker screeching all the while Silva
had put himself between
scp-5683 and the ambitious Foundation
doctor whose hunger for a promotion had
led to all this Carnage the junior
researcher announced his Noble intention
to sacrifice himself occupying the
creature while urging Christensen to run
the doctor shoved Silva towards the
spider and prepared to run then all of a
sudden
scp-5683 vanished Junior researcher
Silva told Dr Christensen he was
disappointed before researcher miles
researcher Hall and security Chief Ade
all entered the bunker through the torn
open hole where the door had been
Christensen questioned where
scp-5683 had gone to which Silva
explained there was little reason to
keep a dummy around once it had served
its purpose as a substitute you
mentioned you worked with a lizard sir
the junior researcher recounted that
there was a Containment Breach if you
don't terribly mind me asking how did
you escape that situation it seemed
quite lethal didn't it afraid and
Confused Dr Christensen asked where he
was Hall and Miles urged him not to ask
questions he already knew the answer to
Silva explained who they all were a jury
specifically Dr christensen's jury and
according to them the ambitious doctor
had disgraced himself again Christensen
had been there for a long time a
considerably long time reliving the same
events over and over again with
scp-5683 acting as a substitute for
scp-682 it was the same situation he'd
made the same decisions the same
mistakes and it had cost lives now Dr
Christensen was trapped in an endless
loop Penance for the casualties that had
occurred at his hands all in the pursuit
of his own selfish personal gain he
asked the jury how long he'd be stuck
there a question Silva responded to with
until you take responsibility sir
immediately Dr Christensen tried to
admit that this all had been his fault
but he didn't mean it not really he
hadn't accepted blame he just wanted a
quick and easy way out of the loop and
the jury of his deceased Personnel knew
it Christensen ran for the door in the
hopes of escaping his fate futile as his
chances were a black iron chain appeared
from around the corner and wrapped
itself around the over-ambitious
doctor's throat ignorant of his pleas
for forgiveness saying he was sorry
wouldn't bring back the people who died
died in service of his aspirations to
becoming a site director the chain drag
Dr Christensen through the facility at
such a speed that he collided with every
wall and every corner as he turned
sharply being pulled along the floor but
that and the walls quickly crumbled away
revealing a sight that made Dr
Christensen start screaming that it
wasn't his fault and he never really
stopped what followed involved a great
deal of blood and fire once it was over
it left behind the same awful stench the
doctor had smelled before and he'd soon
be smelling it again too as the cycle
repeated itself the directive had come
straight from a member of the o5 council
they were impressed with Dr Christensen
and the ambitious Foundation doctor had
been hoping to snag a director position
at site-04 but there was one final test
for Dr Christensen to solve the scp-5683
problem now check out
scp-5000y the full story compilation and
scp-3023 and then it decided to be an
angry spider for more